I'm Rob Greenfield and this backpack is
everything I own
it's about 50 possessions besides being
a person who just generally tries to
live simply
I'm also an environmental activist and
an adventurer trying to do things that
really catch people's attention and get
them to think about our lives does more
stuff make us happier so what are the
possessions that I own first
the clothes on my back one t-shirt and a
pair of shorts along with this t-shirt I
have three more shirts two t-shirts one
long-sleeve all green I have a wool
sweater and then another smaller sweater
long sleeve one pair of pants another
pair of shorts two pairs of boxers and
one pair of socks and then I have one
pair of sandals no shoes I grew up in a
very small town in northern Wisconsin
and I was raised by my single mom along
with my three siblings and my mom made
only around $15,000 a year I had all of
my basic needs met and I had a good
childhood but I always felt like I
didn't have as much as other people
almost none of my friends came over to
my house because I was too embarrassed I
didn't want them to see that I was poor
so I grew up basically hiding my true
self and that created this desire to fit
in to be normal and what I saw as normal
was having a lot of nice stuff I have a
handkerchief with this backpack a
daypack as well so I don't always have
to carry this stuff with me I have a
pillow since I travel quite a bit in my
early 20s I made a goal I wanted to be a
millionaire by the time I was 30 years
old during my summers I was working
between 80 and 90 hours a week making as
much money as I could and then during
the school years I was party generally
three nights a week and my life was very
focused on RTing on pursuing women and
it was largely about an image it was
about pursuing what I saw as the
American dream I became pretty focused
on material possession
and on financial wealth I had two cars I
had a boat and I had a large closet of
clothes and I was definitely creating my
self-worth based on the things that I
had as far as personal care items and
hygiene the things that I have are some
biodegradable soap toothpaste a
toothbrush some essential oil
moisturizer for the body scissors
fingernail clippers dental floss
earplugs and for cutting my hair and my
beard a hand powered razor shaves by
hand now a lot of people see me today
where everything that I own fits into my
backpack and I tell them about my past
and they think there must have been some
sort of major moment of enlightenment
but actually there was nothing like that
what happened was I simply started to
watch a lot of documentaries and read a
lot of books and I started to realize
that almost every single action that I
was taking was destroying the very world
that I loved the food that I was eating
the car that I was driving so I decided
that I wanted to change my life
continuing on I have my money 637 three
thousand seven hundred eighty dollars
this is all of my money no bank account
no credit card no debit card no life
savings or life insurance or insurance
of any sorts nothing owed to me and I
don't owe to anybody else if I was
robbed I could lose everything for a lot
of people that would be scary but for me
it's the ultimate freedom I set out to
start downsizing my life to start being
happy with what I had rather than always
feeling like I needed more first just
went through my possessions and I would
look at them and I'd ask myself do I use
this do I get purpose from this and I
would get rid of the things I wasn't
using and that weren't adding value to
my life I went from a three-bedroom
apartment to eventually living from one
of the rooms into the 6 foot by 6 foot
closet and from there I simplified from
having my apartment to a tiny house
which was a 50 square foot tiny house
and
and I simplified to having dist:111
possessions which I then traveled with
for about two years after that I
actually lived in a hundred square foot
tiny house in Orlando while I grew in
for John percent of my food and then I
went back to traveling and got my life
down to just fifty possessions so it's
been a long process in simplifying I
spent hundreds of hours decreasing the
amount of stuff that I had and changing
my mindset to realizing that I didn't
need those things for identification I
have a passport and I have a birth
certificate technology-wise I have my
laptop two chargers right now one
because I'm here in Europe one for when
I get back to the United States my
headphones and then this is actually a
possession that I don't own I'm actually
borrowing this right now it's a little
microphone I think I only have one life
I'm not going to work away my whole life
to have some freedom at the end of it
I'm gonna live a good life from my
entire life living simply allows me to
do that and it's about living more
sustainably the less that I need the
more I'm able to live in the present
moment
and the more that I'm able to do the
things that really matter not having a
cell phone for example means that when I
am with my friends I'm actually with my
friends rather than having the
distraction of texts coming in or going
to the inbox messages of social media I
have loose leaf tea and then a tea
strainer a water bottle a pot for
cooking as well as a bowl and a to-go
container and then a spoon I have one
book and I always just swap them out
with a new book bookmark which is one of
Gandhi which reminds me to keep life
simple and lastly my notebook and a pen
today I own about 47 possessions but
that does change from day to day that
number is not the most important part of
it it's a goal it's an exercise of
keeping my life really simple I believe
that we need to act now in order to have
a chance for a sustainable future what
we're currently doing isn't working it's
not working overall
the majority of humanity and the other
species that we share this earth with
this is drastic but I believe that we
need drastic measures small little
incremental changes are not enough when
you look at the state of the world today
you cannot have infinite growth on a
finite planet this is about saying no to
finding my purpose and my health and my
happiness in material possessions this
is about me saying no we don't need to
destroy the very earth that we live on
in order to have a quality society and
happy of the human beings and then the
very last thing that I always forget is
on this computer this is a bumper
sticker and yes this counts as a
possession as well it says we must be
the change that we wish to see in the
world and that is my philosophy
[Music]